turmoil in the streets of Venezuela
today as protesters demand president
Nicolas Maduro stepped down and
President Trump is taking the clearest
step yet to show his support for their
cause he announced the u.s. is
officially recognizing the head of the
opposition controlled Congress in
Venezuela as that country's leader but
despite the upheaval Maduro is not
without his supporters and is clamping
down tonight State Department
correspondent rich Edson has the latest
across Venezuela tens of thousands of
protesters demanding president Nicolas
Maduro get out I have felt that people
are believing again Juan Y doe is the
president of the opposition led National
Assembly earlier this week he began a
legal process to try to replace Maduro
and today I swear to formally assume the
powers of the National Executive as
president in charge of Venezuela the
United States agrees this afternoon the
Trump administration officially
recognized Guido as the interim
president of Venezuela president Trump
says quote I will continue to use the
full weight of United States economic
and diplomatic power to press for the
restoration of Venezuelan democracy we
continue to hold the illegitimate Maduro
regime directly responsible for any
threats it may pose to the safety of the
Venezuelan people Maduro says he's
breaking diplomatic relations with the
US and giving American diplomats 72
hours to leave the country there's
little indication Maduro plans to leave
we hope that Nicolas Maduro will accept
a peaceful transition of power in
Venezuela that he will accept the will
of the people to move his country
forward and embrace their new president
a won by though at the White House when
asked whether the US would consider
using military force there president
Trump refused to rule it out we're not
considering anything but all options are
on the table
which is all options always all options
are on the de Medeiros government
dispatched police to the demonstrations
they fired rubber bullets and tear gas
pro-government factions also organized
counter protests the government that
made Chavez the government that has
Maduro now has achieved significant
progress the Trump administration
encourages other governments to join the
u.s. and recognize Guido as Venezuela's
legitimate leader Maduro has called the
opposition little boys under the control
of the Trump administration the United
Nations says three million Venezuelans
have left their country escaping rampant
inflation food and medicine shortages
and violence several US allies in the
region have joined the administration in
recognizing waa-waa as interim president
of Venezuela though Venezuela's defense
minister indicates the country's
military is still behind Nicolas Maduro
Brett Richardson at the State Department
rich thank you